good morning Hank it's Monday I'm at
Bill & Eileen's house Bill and Eileen
were my first bosses or at least some of
my first bosses at bookless magazine I
think Cooper is the reason of course
that I am an author she's an author
herself of books like sam-i-am and the
Golden Rule this is the Korean addition
because Eileen doesn't have an English
edition but anyway this book is
dedicated to me I would show you but the
dedication is in isn't is in Korean so
Hank your video on Friday was amazing
and I still can't get over the fact that
nerdfighters found gussie manlove even
though she wasn't named gussie manlove
when she died she was named to Audrey
Brown and she wasn't named gussie
manlove when she was born she was named
Gussie horsey which is the worst name
ever or at least I thought it was the
worst name ever until I started doing
research on the topic so today Hank I
present you my list of six unfortunate
names from history number six
Dick Trickle Hank when it comes to dicks
you have a lot of unfortunate name
choices like dick sweat the former
congressman or Dick Armey but to my mind
the best at being worst is Dick Trickle
who was a NASCAR driver aside from being
famous for being named Dick Trickle Dick
Trickle was also famous because he was
the only NASCAR driver in history who
had a hole screwed into his helmet so
that he can smoke in the middle of races
he had his pit crew install a cigarette
lighter in his stock car and one time
after a race with very few caution flags
he said that race went by so fast I only
had time for two cigarettes number five
I'm a Hogg the daughter of Texas
governor Big Jim Hogg I'm a Hogg was
known as the first lady of Texas
probably because no one wants to be
known as I'm a Hogg she was a great
patron of the Arts she collected works
by Picasso and Matisse and she was a
philanthropist and she also has an
honorary degree meaning that technically
her name is doctor I'm a Hogg number
four Harry Baals
hey Carrie balls has been much in the
news lately because there is a move by
the city of Fort Wayne to name a
building after their beloved former
mayor Harry Baals his name really was
Harry Baals and he is a very beloved
former mayor like I hear all the time on
talk radio in Indiana people saying you
know those East Coast people they can
tell us you can't name a building the
Harry Baals government Center well what
this town needs is more hairy balls
number three chandelier the daughter of
the guy who founded the Learjet
corporation chandelier grew up to become
a lead singer in swing bands
number two
Hyman Lippmann who was the first person
to ever attach an eraser to a pencil and
number one crispy bacon a composer
living in Los Angeles who writes music
for movies like he contributed music to
such movies as Gnomeo and Juliet Michael
Clayton I am Legend and Hank he wrote
the entire original score for the
American classic Space Chimps also just
to reiterate his name is crispy bacon so
Hank it just goes to show you that
merely having a horrible name like
crispy bacon or gussie manlove doesn't
mean that you can't go on to great
things like writing the score for the
movie Space Chimps
funny named individuals don't lose hope
Hank I'll see you on Wednesday